[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live more incognito
here online podcast lawsongaming.net
and who is this fine gentleman we have
in the realm today hi i'm chris from
assimilate
the party game nice nice so assembly i
like the name by the way
so tell us what is assembling what what
is this game about yeah it's a social
deduction party game
for five to ten players so if you're
familiar with the jackpot series we work
really similarly where
players will use their phone to to play
the game on the tv or computer
okay cool cool so again now now as far
as
release are we out now or is it coming
soon or where are we as far released
uh it's coming out soon actually the end
of the month august 26th it'll be open
for everybody uh ten dollars on steam
uh we do have a closed beta so if you're
interested you can reach out to us and
we can uh maybe get some code sent out
awesome awesome so again we wanna so
again what we're learning right now is
obviously
august 26th give us the detail like the
gameplay specific loop
yeah so i guess one of the easiest ways
to describe it as a part of game is it's
kind of like
code name so it's got a word component
where the characters are trying to
describe
subtly uh what the password is so that
the robot doesn't figure it out
the robot's unaware of what the password
is is trying to bluff their way so it's
kind of got that mafia-esque
or secret hitler social deduction aspect
to it as well
awesome awesome awesome that is pretty
actually funny by the way just listen to
you describe it
so as far as amount of people working on
the game is it solely you is it
there are three of us yeah we have the
designer the programmer and myself like
the producer
three-man team and how what have you
learned during that journey of producing
this game
uh we've learned a lot this is the first
game we've ever made we started it in
march 2020 like
as a covid project like quarantine kind
of thing um
and quite frankly it's been really
really exciting we've learned so much
like
the hardest thing was play testing
because we need at least five people to
test out the game
so getting groups of five to ten people
regularly was daunting when it's all on
zoom
exactly and then it's actually a good
point because during the pandemic
especially right that has to be at least
a little challenging with development
so it's like has that really affected
development to that extent
again just maybe doing everything via
zoom as opposed to being in person
yeah i think it definitely adds a layer
of complexity but it also allowed us to
because of the circumstances we were
forced to have our game be compatible on
long distance plays right so it helped
because we wanted to make sure this game
could be played over zoom
um for player pillars to connect from
wherever so
because of the nature of in which we
were designing or developing the game it
allowed us to
make that front and center if that makes
sense pretty cool man pretty cool to
learn about this stuff
at game development our style looks
pretty fun
pretty pretty cool so i expect i expect
a lot of jokes and laughs with this game
amongst friends so that's gonna be
interesting but
we had to show some love to assimilate
more cognitive and again
just for one more reminder for the
people when can they get their hands on
it
august 26th on steam coming soon august
2016. and could they wish listing can
they get
absolutely yeah wishlist
no doubt a pleasure a civilian thank you
so much
no doubt
[Music]
you